the cancellation of the fame Scripps
National Spelling Bee over the pandemic
is heartbreaking news for the students
who qualified for the event they were
ready to go this is the only time since
World War two that the finals have been
canceled but thanks to the ingenuity of
two former top spellers there is an
opportunity for the students to shine
after all this year Janet shamlian shows
us how the challenge has now moved
online Janet I love all the creativity
that's coming out good morning to you
and it was adorable to watch Gale good
morning to you it was an idea born here
in the Houston area from two young
people who were Spelling champions
themselves they knew what it was like to
prepare for an event like this only then
to have it canceled so they took it upon
themselves to plan and then host a
National Spelling Bee and it all
unfolded via zoom to spell the best
place to show off that talent has been
the annual script Spelling Bee which
this year has been canceled the news hit
hard for brother and sister Shobha and
Chirag - sorry you were in the scripts
be three times I was yes and a
semifinalist oh yeah between the two of
them they've reached the finals five
times the Houston area teams knew it
would be disappointing visit for this
year's finalists if you get all three
parts right so they're hosting their own
National Spelling Bee that is correct
our main motivation for doing it is just
to give these eighth graders the chance
that they wouldn't have had to compete
on scripts or you know just some sort of
like alternate path the dasari started
spelled pundit a spelling bee
preparation company where the virtual
competition was announced for children
up to eighth grade especially for eighth
graders like this would have been like
the last chance to compete in the
National Spelling Bee so it's just kind
of like so
doesn't go to like a complete waste it
may not be the pomp and circumstance of
the national bee but 280 students signed
up and the competition is as fierce as
ever the $2,500 first prize is a drop in
the bucket compared to the 50 grand
Scripps offers it's winner a dust2 earth
on a Christian who went to Scripps last
year and qualified again this year says
it's not about the cash what do you like
about spelling it's like a puzzle you
think outside of the box to find the
parts of the word and put them together
what are your feelings going into this
virtual Spelling Bee
I feel it'll be a new experience and I I
feel like it'll be it'll go well Joba
and Shuba put in favorites to keep some
headers from receiving help but say
they're probably not needed
are you expecting that the honor system
will prevail here
most of these fellows are play
understand the bee they're very
competitive about it I don't think any
of them if they won I don't think they'd
want it to be because they cheated all
right your word is karate and last night
final thi crosstie that's correct
the winner was 14 year old navneet
Morelli from Edison New Jersey or the
champion of the 2020 spell pundit of my
National Spelling Bee
it may not be Scripps but it's still
victory spelled with a capital v so the
competition on zoom' was actually
broadcast on Facebook so everybody could
watch it which I did and I have to say
it was just amazing to watch these kids
they really enjoyed it they made the
most of it and when navneet was crowned
the winner Anthony another little girl
said hey can you unmute us all so we can
all cheer for the champion apparently
the spelling bee world is a small one
and they all know each other Anthony
yeah that's really cool I love I love
how intense and sincere they all are
about everything they're doing I love
that the brother and sister did this
it's so great congratulations to all of
them it's it's it must have been
heartbreaking
the original B was cancelled Jana thank
you so much